hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're
going to continue with some and and
testing for our react native web app so
if you're just joining for the first
time this stream is just me like
actually coding
I don't rehearse anything I will make
mistakes I'll try to do my best to
explain what I'm doing feel free to ask
questions in the live chat so if you're
watching this later on you can put the
questions in the the comments or just
shoot me a message on Twitter or
whatever other social media platform
that you like and I'll split this up
I'll do a 25-minute period of coding and
then I'll go answer some questions in
the live chat so if you put your
question I'm not ignoring you I will get
to it just after a bit of coding so we
are using react native but we're using
something called react native web that
will take all of our react native code
and make it work in a browser so the
benefits of doing that is that we can
then take that same react native code
and run it in Android or iOS or whatever
other platform that works with react
native it also is a nicer development
experience that we can develop right in
the browser and don't have to spend as
much time in an emulator which usually
takes up a lot more your CPU and it's
it's harder to debug alright so I want
to start out by going over this pull
request that I received so you can check
out there's a link in the description
for the github repo all the code is open
source it's it's all in this repo if you
want to add something to the code please
feel free
some issues already and you can check
those out
I'm gonna start my timer since we're
getting into actual code stuff now but
we did get a pull request and I like the
full request and everything that was
done in apt Jas is awesome so basically
what it would it had done is made sure
that the focus went into the input so
here's our game beautiful I know right
so what would happen is you put in let's
say four and then the inputs not focused
any more right so I have to actually
click back in here okay so not a good
experience actually had my kids play
this game a few days ago and that's why
where I got a lot of the issues that I'd
put in over the weekend was just kind of
observing what they were doing so now
after this pull request the focus will
go back so the the thing I have a
question about though and I'm not sure
if you're watching so you did this pull
request Sid siddhu's sorry I'm not sure
to pronounce that but anyway if you're
watching you can just answer me right in
the in the chat so I didn't issue where
the division this game is supposed to be
for children who are just starting to
learn how to do basic math right so the
the issue that I had with the division
was you would divide like single digit
numbers and you could potentially get
decimal numbers and children wouldn't be
able to do that right they probably
don't even have the concept of a decimal
yet at that point so I wanted it so that
when you divide you'd always get
basically you'd always get a whole
number answer okay so I think maybe in
the issue and explain it clearly
because and correct me if I'm wrong it
looks like what this is doing is it's
just taking whatever the answer is from
the division and it's just rounding it
right rounding it it down so what I what
I actually wanted and I put a little
comment here too is what I actually
wanted is to make sure that the problem
given to the user the division problem
would have a whole number answer so for
instance 9 divided by 3 is gonna give
you 3 right just 3 4 divided by 2 is
going to give you 2 but 3 divided by 2
is gonna give you a fraction or a
decimal same way with like 9 divided by
4 right so the user would never be
presented with 3/2 or 9 divided by 4
right so that's more of like what I
wanted and I have a couple ideas for how
to implement that but if anybody else
wants to implement that please go ahead
and to do if I guess so like this part
of the pool request is great and I'm
ready to accept that but this part like
I said I think that needs worked a
little bit differently and that's that's
probably my fault for not for not like
explaining it well enough in the issue
so maybe I'll copy this as well and put
it add it to the issue
yeah yeah I didn't really yeah I didn't
really provide many explanation or
examples okay so hopefully that made
sense and we can go back to some of the
code the testing code and I do want to
say what's up and just check and see
who's here who's watching so hey
everyone I see a lot of you in the live
chat just scrolling through really quick
okay I already see some questions in
there and I will I will get to those
questions as soon as the timer goes off
so hang in there if you can't hang in
there right now if you gotta go do
something that's cool you can always
watch the recording of this later on and
you can hear my answer to your question
there all right so we did some testing
and briefly I'll just go through this
we're using puppets here to run a
headless Chrome browser and then we are
simulating what a user would go through
and verifying that our app does what we
want it to do all right so this is an
end-to-end test if you want to check up
check out like how we set this up this
browser is options Jas in runner Jess
those are the files you want to check
out for the the setup and then the
actual test is just this one file for
now at spec J s if you want to know more
about the tests check out the last
stream so we started this in our last
live stream that I'd done a week ago but
let's let's jump into this so for now
we're just our first test is we're
checking to make sure we can actually
see the title so like this basically
verifies that the page loads and it has
the text on it that we want it to have
right
we also verify that the hero character
can be seen so when I say the hero I
mean this little purple square for now
still need to work out some graphics and
a better color scheme for this although
my kids did like the colors so although
if you start really this doesn't look
great to me it actually may not be bad
for kids so Oh see I think I needs some
more testing user testing before I make
a final decision
on the colors let's see so we're testing
that and what I'd like to test is also
do we have the correct number of enemies
so right now we're testing Edition right
in it we're saying we correct edition
problems should reduce the enemies by
one right and we got pretty far along in
this but not quite so we have our value
one about you two so we're actually
getting the the numbers that are on the
page for our problem
right so and we're getting the okay and
then we're adding these numbers together
right so potentially we would do the
same test for each mode of the game
right which for right now is addition
subtraction multiplication and division
all right but once we get this addition
one working we could pretty much just
copy and paste most of it to get it
working for the other modes all right so
we have it all the way down to where the
user would click Submit and what we need
to do is just figure out okay are there
just two elements left with the class of
enemy so I believe we already added that
class I should verify because our test
definitely is gonna fail if we don't
have anything with that class on it
so it's good our app j/s and check out
our enemies and where's these
oops I went too far yep so we do have a
class name of enemy on all our enemies
all right so let's go back to the test
so what we need to do then is just
figure out in our our tests how to do
this
so I'm thinking that we could
there's gonna be some way to check for
the number of enemies so let's go over
here to our documentation and which I
thought I had some documentation open
from the last time but I guess not all
right so let's let's think what would
this be yeah probably not pop it to your
documentation look at it maybe just
we'll see
all right let's check this out it looks
like I've been here I've been to this
article already and alright let's open
up the documentation for both of these
I was hoping I get lucky and I'd see him
an example of them doing the same thing
instead of having to look at the
documentation but I don't think that's
gonna happen
okay hi so let's check out puppeteer API
puppets here is what actually runs the
interactive documentation this is what
actually runs the headless browser yeah
but we can see we have a lot of options
with the puppeteer API a web page and I
don't I don't actually think that
puppeteer is gonna give us what we want
which is why I opened just as well let's
see if they got a link directly to the
docks
nope not your dog's Elwha docks here we
go knock functions
puppets here API that's what I want okay
I hate to just look through Docs when
I'm doing the coding but I really don't
know what the what's the correct way to
do this is if anybody has an idea or
knows go ahead and throw it in the chat
as well I'll keep trying to look over
and see if you have the answer also let
me make this bit bigger so you can see
what I'm doing okay so and just to be
clear what I need to do is figure out I
need to get the exact number of elements
on the page that have the class name of
enemy describe each
these are not helping me oh you know
what I had last last time now I remember
this I had my other computer open and I
think that's where I actually had all of
the the documentation open and I kept
checking my other computer that's why I
didn't have any documentation open on my
machine maybe I still have it open let's
check this out
and I in fact do have quite a bit of
documentation open on my other screen
right now let's see
the the problem with what I'm doing
right now in testing at least for me is
so I'm using several different testing
like framework so potentially like on
the same page we could be using things
from puppeteer just mocha or chai right
so trying to find the right thing to say
in the documentation has been difficult
this is a good time to remind everybody
this is not a tutorial this is me trying
to figure out how to do things it's
supposed to be a realistic look at how a
software engineer works sometimes it
works out well and I get things done and
sometimes I don't all right so let's
just try something so we had just copied
and pasted this from up here with this
comment so we have our our result now
would be after we've clicked submit
we're gonna check for our inner HTML and
we should be able to expect the result
to contain an instead of here oh we
could say enemy
but we want it you want to enemy's right
so that's the issue all right
and now is let's see just testing the
finite number of all right so if you
couldn't see that I just searched jest
testing find number of elements with
class on page find selector enzyme we're
not using enzyme so that's not gonna
work
yeah let's see jQuery get out of here
[Music]
just use clear
alright let's switch it up react and to
end testing
all right let's look at these for now
Dom manipulations Dom let's see we test
the phony stuff - jQuery code it was
just so click of it it's a fetcher user
just physics
yeah not exactly what we want
hmm all right that actually looks like
an interesting article but not exactly
for what we want to do all right let me
check this
all right harsh it's here what's this
and how should has some ideas you know
using Jess
how should saying you should use Cypress
for Indian testing
all right I've never used Cypress harsh
and says I'm not using ensign oh I'm not
using enzyme since you're not using Jess
wait a second wait a second so just is
not being used at all in here why does
why did I think I'm using yes nope
that's not what I wanted click the wrong
thing so harsh it I mean that actually
makes sense though
so using chai and browser let's just go
to Cypress really quick then because I
don't know what Cypress is
okay
it's actually equal shoe okay so the
syntax looks very similar to all the
normal testing syntax all right so why
what what then is better about Cypress
than puppeteer it seems like Cypress
maybe does more than puppeteer
correct uh okay arch it says it'll take
time to move to Cypress
Oh Michael said Jess was removed from
package.json so just actually is
installed with create react app so it's
there it's just not in the package.json
like it's it's it comes with react
scripts alright so let's just make it
work with this one then okay our should
says Cypress is a complete framework
better UI all right I'll have to check
out Cypress then later on today and see
if that's something we want to switch to
we're really not that far along with
testing so switch shouldn't be too bad
alright so harsh it's saying we could
just check element length just check the
length okay
Thanks
it takes something we have to say it is
sorry I'm looking at the look at it the
live chat all right so our since
you know what you're doing here help me
out here so I need to check the elements
dot length so can I get HTML so do I
need to check like could I just directly
I guess what I'm asking is am i doing
the check off of result off of the inner
HTML then enemies result
okay I should saying don't use result no
don't use the result harsh it asks if we
could do the live share I don't have the
Villa's code last year set up on this
computer system what users old you see
it says close okay so don't use result
use CSS class okay
yeah I can't use the link but I think my
timer went up okay timer went up let's
say crate and let me answer some
questions right now a lot of people just
saying hi asking what language this is
and it's in JavaScript
let's see okay here's a question Carl
says I think Jessie should take a coding
challenge from us and you should program
a slot machine game using react native
web a slot machine game I'd never
thought of doing that maybe maybe we can
do that Carl says next project must be a
slot machine or card game using direct
native web say that you accept the
challenge I don't know I think about it
I'll think about accepting the challenge
obvious says would you recommend C++ for
game developing I don't I don't know I
don't know what the best is for game
development so I'm not the probably the
best version to give advice can you
suggest to me a video where I can learn
all about the basics of C language check
out the cs50 courses from Harvard
they're all on YouTube the first maybe
like the third weekers third video or
something I believe they go over basics
of C so check out that I mean it's I
don't think it's in the first video but
definitely within like the first few
videos they they go over see a rune asks
what is software testing basically like
in in this case we're doing automated
testing so we create a program that runs
our app and test it test the app right
you could also do like testing weird
like an actual person test your your app
and that's important too to do them both
but that's what I mean by testing
creepy-ass should I go for Microsoft
certification for web I don't really
know I don't know anything about
Microsoft's web certification
Milana world says I don't know what you
do Jessie but I'm still learning I'm
busy with HTML CSS and JavaScript says
that it looks cool hopefully I'll get
there what are you doing
this is react native and we're doing
testing for react native so but keep it
up at the HTML CSS and JavaScript when
you good with that you can move on and
do react if you want let's see
P ASIS I am your biggest fan can you
please do videos about hi again I really
need to know I don't know anything about
that so I probably won't do videos uh
let's see
getting almost Hugo says oh this is sort
of like pair programming yeah it's it's
kind of like it's kind of like pair
programming except there's a lot more
people who involve gap says it's like
8:00 a.m. and you out of your coding
respect yeah yeah it is so we started at
7:30 it is early but this is the only
time a day that I can like reliably do
this this coding show the Gus's love and
saw all your videos nice and very
knowledgeable oh thanks I appreciate
that guca rod says is Java enough for
getting a job oh yeah there are a ton of
Java jobs available so they hire Java
developers where I work all the time
Hugo says cs50 is a bit hard for a total
newbie cs50 could be but I don't know
they start you out really easy like it
starts you always scratch so but you're
right I mean I didn't do look at even
the cs50 videos to I'd already been a
developer for a couple years so I guess
I don't know what it'd have been like if
I had tried it as a total newbie but but
it's supposed to be an intro to computer
science class so it's supposed to be
okay even for for new people
okay I actually got through the
everything in the chat if I happen to
miss your question just ask it again or
put in the comments or something all
right let's go
I don't think I'm gonna be able to do an
entire Pomodoro session I'm gonna have
to finish up before that so let me just
mark down where we left off at 8:00 in
the chat oops
802 so I can come right back to there
all right now let's get at the very
least this test working before we end or
at least try our best to get this test
working this is actually way harder than
I anticipated it would be
it seems like an easy thing but since
I've never done it it's kind of hard
okay so let's go back here and say
okay so we need to get the number of
elements on the page so our selector is
going to be enemies right is that what
it is I need to double check and make
sure it's not enemy I think it is enemy
but let's double check enemy yep okay so
selectors enemy and
I wonder if we could do
so like instead of eval body on the page
like can we grab so page dot and that
would be puppeteer I'd be a puppeteer
thing so swipe page
let's see what we have for a page page
on not page on page selector yay I
returns I'm stalking clearly selected
within the page if no one what matches
return value is null okay so I don't
want that with the number if no one
should return I so it will resolve to an
empty array so I'm assuming it would be
an array so we need to use dollar sign
dollar sign selector those sign dollar
sign and let's call this enemies get rid
of this
actually we can scroll this say number
of enemies and you should be able to do
dot length right number of enemies is
declared alright and let's go number of
enemies to equal
alright let's see see if that works
first let me see come on number of
enemies he's got ok cool so that's what
heart should is saying - awesome I do
want to say like so I took that out on a
five or six minute break and before the
break like my brain was just totally
flustered right like I was sure like I
have no idea what to do here after the
break it seemed like it was very clear I
just thought like okay fine like I had
my brain and accepted the fact that I
was mistakenly looking at the wrong
documentation which are should inform me
of as well but I just took me a second
to wrap my mind around the fact that
like the page that we get from puppeteer
would have different methods on it
so anyway I'm just saying that to say
like it's definitely a good idea to take
periodic breaks I love the Pomodoro
Technique which is 25 minutes of code
five minute break it's happened just now
to me but it's happened a lot of other
times that I'm stuck on a problem
because in my mind like I'm thinking
this is the way to fix it this is the
path but in reality there's that's the
that's a dead end right I'm this is the
wrong way to go about it and then when I
take a break and think about something
else for a couple minutes and come back
to it it's almost like a reset and it
just frees up my brain to take a
different path right so it's it's
counterintuitive that taking it time off
would help you do something faster but
that has happened to me so many times so
anyway I definitely recommend that all
right cool
so I actually I do want to test this so
I want to test the test so let's run
yarn ii ii ii ii Act I think that's what
I did
let's check it out ete yep yarn ete
should run this and we'll get an idea of
whether this works nope
alright let's see what the problem is no
node found for selector answer inputs
oops
did we not maybe I didn't do that let's
go to our app file and let's find our
input native ID answer input okay we
should have an answer input no node
phone for selector answer input all
right let's check that out again answer
answer what did I do
hmmm so we're trying to type in to
answer input and we're gonna put the
answer in there so this should be
correct I'm just I'm gonna copy that and
then paste so that we have for sure
exactly the same thing oh I see what the
problem is it was camelcase here and it
was not camelcase there all right let's
switch that up then well at least that's
an easy fix
silly mistake but easy fix you usually
like in JavaScript you camelcase
everything or these most things but in
when you're doing these selectors no
selectors submit did I not put submit on
the button like when you're doing
selectors like with CSS and HTML the
standard is usually 2 - 8 things so I
tend to just go with that it just
bothers me to see camelcase stuff in the
Dom so
that's why I do it like that native ID
submit all right no node found for
selectors submit now I know we have a
button called submit right native ID
submit right we have answer input they
obviously found that submit sub s you be
MIT s you be MIT all right we have it
let's verify like in the Dom that that
is there okay so here's what MIT button
let's inspected and see it should have
the ID does it not do we not have the ID
submit here
all right let's check this out sgb MIT
wait a second that's just weird
that's really weird
we don't have an ID
mm-hmm all right so go back to our code
double check what we're doing okay so we
have this button we have submit it's
it's possible that you can't put a
native ID on a button I know you can do
it on touchable opacity so let's switch
it to touchable opacity and this is
going to take button
oops area touchable opacity there we go
and we'll need inside of here we can't
do the title anymore
so what we're gonna do whoa hold on
oops I guess that went on the wrong one
and I guess I need to keep the button in
there for that one
okay so touchable opacity allows you to
kind of like do more with a button so
you can check it out we may bring up the
documentation in a second touch capacity
and let's add inside of there a view and
LED text and we'll say submit yeah we
don't need to title and I think this
should work is the bare minimum we need
for touchable opacity let's see if that
does what we want all right so this the
styling is gonna be off so like button
comes with styling touchable opacity
does not so we need to add our own
styling which is fine yep here we go now
we have the ID submit so let's try that
again all right so it's kind of good to
know evidently you can't directly put an
ID on a button now I think about it
maybe there is a way to do it and I just
need to look it up but I actually almost
always use touchable opacity instead of
button because I normally want to have
different styling anyway
alright so now that we verify that the
submit' ID is on the page let's see what
air we get now I expected undefined
equal okay so we got undefined with our
with our tests all right so now we
actually have an issue with the test so
page she sort of wait and we wanted a
page and we're trying to get the enemy
so maybe this doesn't return what I
thought it would return okay so I
thought it would return whoops
to get rid of this stuff we don't need
I thought this would return an array
with the elements in it let's see what
it actually returns so it's it's
returning so we it says what it's
running like with the JavaScript is so
let's see if we can run this we'll go to
the console and we'll say document query
select there all and I'm assuming we can
just put in the enemy oops what do we
get here
okay we got three which is correct all
right so let's see let's do it again but
then say dot length and we should get
three good now what we should have if we
get the right answers is actually two
all right so this works let's verify now
that that's what we actually wrote in
our code so page dollar sign dollar sign
dot enemy dot length and here we have
page dot means
hmm
yeah I mean that looks so looks like
that's what we're doing right
okay Harshit says you need to do the
length in the next line okay cool
so I guess then that that won't work
doing the chaining the length on so
let's do let's switch this up and say
sorry I'm I like I needed a different
keyboard or something this is just too
different from what I'm used to using at
work anyway a number of enemies equals
enemies dot length and we'll change this
to enemies now let's do test
all right failed whatever you feel
correct addition answer reduces enemies
by one expected for two equal to hey we
got an actual number but it looks like
alright so this would seem that maybe we
got the answer wrong and we actually
have four enemies so let's let's see
what happens here all right so we're
getting these values and we're trying to
add the values do we need to do answer
equals so I you want to fulfill you to
these are probably coming through as
strings maybe we need to have them be
not strings what do you think oh her she
just said they are strings okay ooh and
harsh it says for button you can
actually use test ID instead of native
ID and that'll work
alright so that's good to know how do we
do this is it part parse int right is
that let's show it yeah of course and
that's what we want
and I think the base is optional so like
we already have like the base defaults
to base 10 I believe maybe not
anyway % oh yeah let's parse int and
just be sure let's say base 10
so like this base here like base-10 is
like our normal number system like if we
put two it would be in binary right so
that's where the base is I'm not gonna I
would assume that base ten is the
default but I did I didn't see that it
said that and the documentation so I'm
not gonna assume it I'm just gonna put
that in there all right let's see if
that makes the difference then and we
get a correct answer text is not
iterable what did I do
I type error text is not interval
okay harsh it says it does default to
ten all right that's cool what the heck
am I doing with this text is not
iterable type error
Harshit says pass it like this okay Oh
Rush's saying maybe we need to give
puppet to your string yeah that makes
sense it was getting a string before now
it's shoot nè it's not define the dollar
sign is not defined maybe
oops template literal so I didn't catch
that
thanks for the verification okay and
those are Curly's I I think I need to
increase my font size not on this screen
that you can see but on my other screen
because I I couldn't even tell those
four curly brackets I thought they're
parentheses okay let's give that a shot
Harsha it's good to be working with you
again I love it
sweet and that worked awesome all right
cool so at some point I stated I just
wanted to at least get this test working
and evidently it works I would say if
anybody wants to do other tests like
this go ahead but Harshit said that he
wants to switch this over to using
Cyprus which actually is really cool I'm
I'm interested to see how Cyprus works
all right cool
so let's save this before I finish up
with the rest of the questions get
status all right those are the files
that I worked on so that makes sense
get commit we're gonna commit and do
a.m. and that's gonna let us so say test
a test for addition
push all right cool
that should be on github now and I think
I got a saw a message in there about
this that pool request that it's updated
or something like that did I
okay so I have to check that out and
pull that in because I want to make sure
I get to these questions if there are
any more questions and then get to work
on some more react native for for my
normal job let's see alright let me go
back to where we started
Gil Gil vein give on I'm not sure I
pronounced that so apologies says I'm
from Brazil I really like your channel
thank you for saying that I appreciate
that thanks for watching Mike will added
so we were talking about the cs50 course
earlier and whether or not it was good
for beginners and Michael Creole says
cs50 is designed for new excuse me it's
designed for noobs if you start at the
beginning
and i i i do agree i think like so
normally your intro to computer science
class would be like CS 100 or 101 right
so cs50 is like as far as i can remember
the whole idea of the class was that you
could come into it like your major in in
university could be something totally
different than computer science but you
could still take this course and and do
well and understand it so at least it's
it's supposed to be like that i didn't
go through the whole course i just did
the first couple of videos so i don't
know how difficult it actually gets so
the first couple videos were you said i
mean pretty pretty easy to understand
Susu Fein says thanks for sharing your
knowledge you're welcome thanks for
watching
Justin says can someone please give me
the breakdown of what we're making sorry
I just joined yeah if you want a more
in-depth breakdown watch like video 1 or
2 video ones kind of rough we had some
technical difficulties maybe video to be
better but basically we're just making
an app that helps children to learn
basic math it just they can practice
their math problems it gamma Phi's it a
little bit so it's it's a little bit
more fun for them actually so my kids my
9 year old and my 7 year old both likes
to play it so they were just excited to
be able to play any type of game I think
hmm
okay justices thank you so it's a game
yep yeah it's again and I'm not like a
game developer so I I like I've done
like things that I suppose you could
call them games but they're not legit
games before so this is not at all like
if you want to learn how to be a game
developer I'm probably not the person
you want to learn that from but I dunno
react native and I dunno web development
so that's more like where I'm coming
from I'm just trying to make a game like
really flick for my children and I want
to try to release this on in the App
Store's
at some point if I think it's decent so
that other kids could also potentially
get some benefit from it so that's
that's what I'm doing this
Justin says you can make whatever you
want I just love coding des Oh awesome
thank you alright cool well I've gotten
through the everything in the chat like
I said earlier if I miss your question
just put it in the comments you can also
follow me on social media I have so the
link to my youtube channel is in the
description if you go there I have all
my different social media links
available for my channel so check them
out if you want to you know message me
on social media also if you like this
you know you can follow free code camp
and set the notifications so you'll get
notified whenever I'm going to go live
occasionally I do some videos and
livestreams on my own channel if you're
interested in that please check that out
subscribe and you'll get notifications
for that as well I'm gonna try to be
back on Friday I'm not sure last Friday
I think I ended up not feeling well and
slept in and so I didn't stream so
apologies for that but I really want to
try to stream at least twice a week so
I'm gonna try to get another one in this
week so just be looking out for that
like I said you get the notification if
you're subscribed and I do post on
social media LinkedIn Facebook Twitter
and Instagram before I stream so you
will get updates there before stream
happens and if you miss it you can
always catch the recording later on okay
so until next time have a great day have
a great rest of the week and I don't
know what we'll work on next time
that'll be to be decided but until then
I see it